chris skidmore is the latest person to
say something publicly what's he saying
so this is the third mp in the space of
about i don't know the last 10 minutes
jane who's just who's not resigning from
a ministerial post but is someone who is
just putting on record in a letter that
they no longer support the prime
minister so we had robert halfon we had
he's a senior mp who's served in
government we had lee anderson a red
wall mp and now we've got chris skidmore
and he's also a former minister he says
that he he's tweeted a letter saying he
no longer has confidence in the prime
minister what's interesting is he is
very strong on this issue of chris
pincher and why it was so important he
said recent events have revealed the
prime minister was informed about this
about these allegations of sexual
misconduct and he says in responding to
these events the prime minister was not
truthful to the media to his own
advisors and to number 10 officials and
this is an extremely grave situation
that is tantamount he says to an
effective cover-up of sexual abuse which
would never be tolerated in a normal
functioning workplace and he says the
fact that he's only come to light after
the no-confidence vote mp's held means
that things are different now and he's
calling on the 1922 committee which is
the committee of conservative mps to
urgently reconsider the rules to allow
another vote this is an mp saying
we didn't get to the threshold before
but now with more information coming to
light we probably should have another go
and the 1922 committee to remind viewers
to change a leader because he leads the
conservative party as well as the
country uh it is the 902 committee of
back bench mps who have to vote to
remove him and because they voted
a month ago and because they voted to
keep him he's safe for 12 months they're
thinking of changing it and they're
having a meeting the rules of this
committee are not written down anywhere
it's all a bit opaque but essentially
they're having a meeting on wednesday
night tonight
and they what they they are now electing
a new executive which is the 18 people
who kind of run it and
um that new executive who are going to
be in place tonight may well include
some of the prime ministers fiercest
critics people like steve baker and
andrew bridgen who've made clear they
are running in order to get rid of the
prime minister that if they change the
rules and it would need a straight
majority
that process could all start getting in
motion pretty quickly and it's been put
to me that it may actually take until
the autumn to really actually get going
and turn into a leadership challenge but
it is possible that they do it before
mps go off for their summer holidays on
the 22nd of this month so things could
all move quite quickly but you've now
got mps urging them to do something
saying we want another vote now so if it
doesn't happen by the end of today it
could happen in the next two weeks well
it may be only next week that they
actually get to have a vote because
there's a whole procedure around it but
of course that can all be changed so
they're having their meeting tonight
we'll see if the prime minister's
critics get on the committee but things
could all start moving quite quickly